as hundreds of thousands of americans
got hooked on opioids
one family the sacklers raked in
billions of dollars
from their suffering but the sacklers
didn't act alone gerald posner is an
investigative journalist he's written an
entire book on the opioid epidemic
we had a fascinating conversation with
him here's part of it
2007 perdue had to plead guilty to
felony misbranding misrepresenting the
drug is not addictive enough and
and too safe and everything else 600
million dollar fines 34 million dollars
paid by the top three executives
and if we spoke the week after that i
would have said to you it's over
that's it doesn't matter if they have
frank luntz or they have mckinsey or
whoever else
they're not going to sell big numbers
anymore and boy would i have been wrong
because it's from 2008
after they plead guilty after there's a
compliance agreement after the
department of justice is supposed to
watch them they have their biggest sales
from 2008 on
they bring in mckinsey the great you
know firm to say okay frank luntz is
good but we need the big guys here we
need mckinsey
and mckenzie tells them how to turbo
charge sales in 2013 when sales are down
100
million dollars and every year they're
taking out 800 million the family
900 million a billion in 2015 they make
the forbes
wealthiest families list and forbes
calls them the oxyclan
uh when they came onto the uh forbes
what did mckinsey tell them mackenzie
told them
this is fantastic you you need to
increase
the sales representatives who are going
out the detail team those who are
selling the drugs directly to the
doctors convincing them to do it
by 20 percent make them make more visits
and
don't have them waste their time on the
low prescribing doctors because that's
not really worth it
go just for the high prescription yeah
go to the ones who are sending out a lot
of pills
what i think a lot of people who first
read about this story 20 years ago said
to themselves well that's really sad
people are dying of drug addies in their
hand you know addicts od
and they're addicts and like your
sympathy for an addict is limited
because they're an addict and they're
reviled
my mind was changed when i read the
numbers the numbers of pills coming into
certain zip codes particularly in
appalachia and kentucky and west
virginia
and parts parts of ohio were so high
that it didn't seem to me that any
honest and decent pharma executive could
read these in the monthly report and
think that was okay
yeah it's impossible it's about you know
you can't get away with it they knew
where there was heavy concentrations
they never reported any of this to the
fda they never reported anything back to
the dea
they just said they put on their
blinders and said let's pocket the money
there's a lot of responsibility by the
way to go around on the opioid crisis
it's not just purdue it's not just this
it's the fda it's the lax fda it's the
the middle distributors it's greedy
doctors it's doctors running pill mills
there's no questions it's pharmacists
who are willing to cut the rules and
look the other way to fill a
prescription that shouldn't be done
so you know the sacklers will take the
brunt of the blame because they are the
owners of this star drug that
caused so much devastation and left in
his wake but there's plenty of blame to
go around
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else